let me tell you this this is my first
custom piece she actually had red
bottoms on but the paint chipped off or
whatever and you know she got a Bigfoot
cash doll on the rocks
take one my first piece of jury it was a
charm with my name like four hundred
dollars and I was working at Little
Caesars at the time but like every tick
I'll take you like $5.00 out and go put
it on there on the charm cause in
layaway the layaway or something where
you actually don't have to go and put
all the money on it to get it you just
pay on it until you pay it up and then
good so I was I was catching the bus up
to the this place called Northland in
Michigan after I got off work with my
check for $25 on there like every other
week cuz I got paid every two weeks when
I finally got it I just felt like I was
on top of the world like I left out of
here and it's just like my whole inside
was like like a diamond like I was just
shining and it only has a couple stones
in it it was not like cuz I'm foreign
dollars but it was so cute to me and I
got into a fight in lawsuits yeah I was
younger you know so I was just nothing
but and then Joe rodeos came up a
Jolokia is a watch I just know it was to
be a watch it was popular I wanted the
hottest that was I guess what I get
alright so at this time I'm working at
best but I did your rodeo was like $900
I'm different I was living on my pieces
I like cashing out like I do now
I guess mind your rodeo I go to work I'm
the best buy they had they told me I
couldn't go there no more when I'm like
why I like us you talking about the
watches and we're talking about selling
TVs and I'm like putting any cool Don't
Look magazine in helmet like I'm from
Detroit Michigan and that's what we're
into where we're not just into jewelry
into fashion we're like a show-me-state
like when I was in high school there's
stuff like it was really like a fashion
show like we're into that you know
wearing some weeks and and and Gators
and hair and cartier frame like the
pimps and audit the suit suit that's
just us is it me and I know me as in me
you know the ladies fashion cars all
that that's who I am
I think the most Detroit piece I have is
like this hash dollar ring and it's cash
it off bracelet this ring right here -
no ring I saw of course and as you've
got my name with my logo on there cuz I
used to be a dancer and I had took a
picture with a bag of money of a Louis
Vuitton bag it was I mean it was a new
picture whatever that was seven years
ago
however I took these pictures and I got
it molded
and that's been my logo is it stuck with
me because it's so fly I had on red
bottoms with nothing on but Louie
Vuitton bag full of money
yeah you can't see the photo but the dip
the Diamonds now so this bracelet right
here this is a half carat bracelet this
actually if anybody know about that
color this key color and these are real
stones
I mean you got like a good color stone
and you got good fire dance see think
with me I don't really just have Jerry I
have diamonds certain diamonds on your
head out in the Sun and that's the thing
you can get people that have a lot of
jewelry and I like it definitely
investment that's why don't get juries
if I get diamonds that's a different
that's a difference that's why I get
quality if I'm gonna buy it I'm gonna
buy it or I rather not have it so I take
my time it's forever it's a marathon
with the jury babe I want to shine when
I'm all but some people they jury only
trying certain lights why'd you even
shine because I've told you this is
inversely I've never want to stop buying
jury sometime won't I'm always going by
jerk you see like I use a got of Cuban
anklet on I got this one
la his name is Isaac I shot an Amana ice
me up
I want Angel City I want oddish y'all
know I be stunts and then this one right
here is the Katie diamond this bracelet
I got from my cash bread my fans they
iced me out for my birthday
hey I thought a lot of cares for us you
know I call them brats because they're
sports they want all of me they want
music they want me to have kids what is
there so I like have a special
connection with them because
you know I have situations that happened
to me and all I had was my Sansa Keaton
going and they just really kept putting
my music up when it was getting taken
down they were I love them so this is
like my favorite little piece right here
my bracelet that's my favorite piece and
this one like a Cuban Linx oh okay they
they play the cash burns don't play this
right here is a Gucci believe this a
two-tone white gold rose gold I also got
this one from Angel City so that's a
little choker
you know when I'm filming it depends on
how I'm feeling - I got moves I'm like
nine difficult depends on who I am this
day today I feel like Katie
I got Katie Cash Donkey [ __ ] midnight it
just depends I love my daddy my daddy
died on my first birthday so that's my
favorite piece these are also half
carats each color vs tones I got this
made in April of 2018
I just noticed cost a lot this is one of
the most expensive pieces that I have a
little bit over he's shining my daddy
likes time he told me nice and mild so I
did
we're gonna talk about the day just so
we got the day just to Tom this is rose
gold white gold this also came from
Angel City by ever I haven't won all
right so this is catch-up
I'm filling my cash doll that's it
this is an AP this to time it's limited
white gold and rose gold
it's a flower said see I still got the
Silas stones and the links right here
this 116 when all the praise like 70
years like that cost like seven because
it's just continuous limited edition I'm
a limited edition type I don't really
like wearing stuff everybody else had
you know I'm saying I like to have my
own pieces I want I'm unique so this is
a Rolex this is another day just so when
I feel alright miss Knight I put this on
I feel real bossy little bit guess this
is a plain ap this was my first ap
that's why I'm getting something like
flower City the flower said and hit hard
I feel like a prawn said my other say
they like set apart these are all
together so they just take paints it's
like a different type of dance they just
working they acting a damn fool and I'm
not I don't even know so this right here
this is a Gucci link
this right here is caught fancy yellow
diamonds right here these are emeralds
and it's just Cuban Cuban link diamond
links diamond links this is stones these
just arms man I like bracelets I'm a
woman
[Music]
but this key is the Detroit skyline cuz
I'm gonna clean well I really like to
say I'm gonna princess of the city
everybody call me the queen bond between
the hip-hop and this is a skyline with
the court with a crown up here and my
name on the back cash off this cash
dollar piece I didn't talk about this
my best friend bought this for me this
year so 2017 2018 2019 I got this for my
birthday and this piece got to keep
diamonds in the back also gold and white
gold
when I first beat my first custom charm
and that was $10,000 and I thought there
was so much I was like oh my god I got a
piece of crust $10 dollars I don't want
to buy to speak to me
I was just different I just I walked
into the club and I was just I sit there
and I just looked at everybody in
disgust say no here is a ring I have put
the pink diamond in the middle heart
ring this won't this marine was like
20,000 I got this ring Golden Sun then
I'm married to the money
party your glasses Detroit is this
really try style car tears its bucks you
want to get him with white as pot you'll
have some white pair I don't know that a
wise they get but I have some pretty
good white color
I have rolls though I have my rose gold
trunk I don't like mine go put this
Detroit straight bags come buffalo horns
where we have a whole movement all
buffed up like all-white Buffy make them
just want to put me you got wires yeah
bullets you have different type of
Cartier glasses or Japan so I have some
wires and you're reliable
I have a lot of I want to get a
dollhouse a big doll house made and I
want to be and I want you to be able to
open it
and you see how down Houston already
have the four sections that stairs
coming down this felt like that and I
want to happen okay so make sure you
stay tuned cuz I'm gonna show you how to
dial house piece period and
if when y'all took my idea just know
you're hurting here first
[Music]